[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW RALLES: Welcome
to Talks at Google.
My name is Andrew Ralles,
and it's a thrill for me to--
hey, Johnny.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Hi.
ANDREW RALLES: It's
a thrill for me
to host our guest today, jazz
pianist and vocalist Johnny
O'Neal.
And a little bit about Johnny--
he's originally from
Detroit, Michigan
and got a start playing
some different kinds
of music, gospel and R&B, before
turning his attention to jazz.
But he worked as a
professional musician
from a very young age
in Detroit, but also
in Birmingham, Alabama,
as well as St. Louis.
He caught the attention
of some jazz masters
at a young age, which
opened up a lot of doors,
people like Barry Harris,
as well as Ray Brown.
But Johnny moved to New
York City in the early 1980s
and performed with Clark Terry.
He also joined Art Blakey
and The Jazz Messengers
during that time.
In 1985, he performed
at Carnegie Hall,
opening for one of his
idols, Oscar Peterson,
playing solo piano.
But he left New
York City in 1986
and spent the next 25 years
living in different places,
like Atlanta,
Georgia, spending time
back in his hometown of Detroit,
Michigan, and back in St. Louis
as well.
Just a couple of more
accomplishments--
he was inducted into the Alabama
Jazz hall of Fame in 1998.
That was one of the first Jazz
Hall of Fames in the country,
I'm told.
And in 2004, his
career hit new heights.
He made it to the silver screen.
He was in the movie
"Ray" with Jamie Foxx,
playing the role of Art Tatum,
who was one of the greatest
pianists of all time--
I believe at the recommendation
of Oscar Peterson.
But he's been back here in
New York City since 2010
and he has what are
called residencies
or recurring gigs at different
clubs throughout the city.
One is Smoke Jazz and Supper
Club on 106th and Broadway.
His new album is
called "In the Moment."
It's on the Smoke
Sessions label.
And quickly, just my
connection to Johnny--
I've been a huge fan
since the first time
I heard him play at Smoke
about five years ago.
I was just completely
overwhelmed.
And I should also mention
that my friend Damon
Smith is the associate
producer of Johnny's new album.
And together with
producer Paul Stache,
they found a way to
make this event happen.
So I'm very thankful.
So, welcome.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Well,
welcome as well.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW RALLES: So again,
the name of the new album
is called "In The Moment."
JOHNNY O'NEAL: "In
the Moment," yes.
And for a while, we had
thought about the title
of this new recording.
Actually, it's
Paul Stache's idea
to come up with "In the Moment."
I think I had a couple
of different titles.
I believe there was
first tropical breeze,
being in love with you.
Then "In the Moment"
was the best solution
because that's the way I like
to perform, is in the moment.
I think we all like to
do things in the moment.
We don't want to plan
everything we do.
Had to be spur of the moment.
You tend to have a little more
love and excitement for it
when it's in the moment, bam!
[LAUGHS]
ANDREW RALLES: It's just very
representative of your sets--
JOHNNY O'NEAL: And also,
it wasn't really planned.
Actually, the repertoire
wasn't really planned
that what we were going to
play, as my guys could tell you.
We went in the studio.
I mean, I had songs in
mind that I wanted to play,
but as the session went
on, then I would just
add more tunes
right in the moment
that we hadn't
talked about playing.
Is that not right, guys?
Yeah.
ANDREW RALLES: I
heard Ben speaking
before about learning
a tune the day
before right there on the spot?
JOHNNY O'NEAL: They told me I
always put them on the spot.
They tell me at
times, listen, Johnny,
we've never played
this tune before.
Really?
I thought we had.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW RALLES: So you
keep them on their toes.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Well, they
keep me on my toes as well.
The future belongs to the youth.
I strongly believe that it's a
reciprocal kind of admiration
you have for the young people.
And the reason I
feel that way is
because I was tremendously
blessed when I was young.
Fortunate enough to
play with the masters--
to Dizzy Gillespie,
Milt Jackson, Blakey's.
So when all these young
artists play with me,
they play on all my experience.
They play on all
the great masters
that I was graced to
play with, you see.
It's my destiny to
keep this music alive.
No America, no jazz.
It's only true art form.
And jazz musicians can
go anywhere in the world
where other musicians can't go
because it's the only true art
form--
the highest level of performance
on a musical instrument.
That's right.
ANDREW RALLES: I know you've
been traveling a lot recently.
Tell us about some of the
places you've been to.
[LAUGHS]
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Well, just this
year, we've been in New York
twice.
We went to Israel, Russia, Nice.
Where else, guys?
SPEAKER 3: Detroit.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Detroit, yes.
ANDREW RALLES: How was that,
coming back to your hometown?
JOHNNY O'NEAL: It had been
about three or four years
since I played there, so they
really welcomed me back home.
And having these wonderful young
gentlemen represent me there,
it was great.
Give them a nice hand.
[APPLAUSE]
I actually travel quite a bit.
And I guess both of the guys and
I have been in the band a year
now.
A year for you and how
long for you, Itay?
Almost a year.
And they're wonderful
man and it's so blessed
to just see their
faces in Europe
and seeing all those audiences,
concert houses, audiences
just so in awe with the young
talent, more so than myself.
Oh yes, absolutely.
ANDREW RALLES: So we
were talking a little bit
before about some
of the pianists that
have influenced you.
And I know you're
able to incorporate
so many different styles
and make them your own.
And I was thinking maybe we
could go over to the piano
and you could demonstrate
some of those people that
have influenced you.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Well,
first for starters,
I started out playing gospel.
And I would have to give
all the praise and glory
to the great Aretha Franklin.
She was actually the first
one I heard play gospel piano.
And so I would
like to demonstrate
a little bit of her style.
When I first heard this rhythmic
style with no rhythm section,
just piano, and just
hear the rhythm--
this is a gospel hymn
entitled "While The Blood is
Running Warm in Your Veins."
Here it is.
[MUSIC - "WHILE THE BLOOD RUNS
WARM"]
And they use this as the rhythm.
You can hear the pedal.
[MUSIC - "WHILE THE BLOOD RUNS
WARM"]
Amen.
ANDREW RALLES: Wow.
[APPLAUSE]
How about Art Tatum?
I know he was one of the
greatest of all time.
And he was able to play a lot--
JOHNNY O'NEAL:
Well, I will play.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOHNNY O'NEAL: I can't
play like Art Tatum,
but I try to conceptually
think like him, which I'm still
trying to figure it out.
OK well, actually in the
movie he mentioned earlier,
I've played four songs,
but only one tune
made it to the
silver screen, which
is Jerome Kern's "Yesterdays."
So here it is.
You'll never hear
his version again.
I don't know what I'm
going to do with it,
but this is influenced
by the great Art Tatum.
Also with the eye, the
whole-- remember the photos
when he had one eye.
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC - JEROME KERN,
"YESTERDAYS"]
Nice piano.
[MUSIC - JEROME KERN,
"YESTERDAYS"]
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW RALLES: OK, should we
bring up the rest of the band?
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Absolutely.
ANDREW RALLES: All
right, sounds good.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Let's welcome--
That's Itay Morchi at
the drums and cymbals.
[APPLAUSE]
Ben Rubens on the
bass and strings.
[APPLAUSE]
OK, I'd like to
play a composition
from my new recording
"In the Moment."
This is an original composition.
This is entitled "CGLS."
So here it is.
We hope you enjoy it.
Here we go, one,
uh-uh, uh uh uh-uh.
[MUSIC - "CGLS"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Now we're going to play
some straight ahead.
We're going to swing some
right down the middle,
"I've Got the
World on a String."
Ooh, here we go.
[MUSIC - "I'VE GOT THE WORLD ON
A STRING"]
[APPLAUSE]
This is another composition that
did so well by Whitney Houston.
This is called "Saving
All My Love for You."
With a little waltz flavor.
[MUSIC - "SAVING ALL MY LOVE FOR
YOU"]
[APPLAUSE]
At the end of the
day, you don't know
what love is until you learn
the meaning of the blues.
You like the blues?
I've got the Google blues.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Google, Google, Google.
[LAUGHS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[HUMMING]
Google is all around the world.
And we travel.
[BLUES MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
I'd like to now play a
beautiful tune I believe-- is it
on the recording?
I'm trying to think of the
solo pieces [INAUDIBLE]..
What tune [INAUDIBLE]
on the record?
SPEAKER 4: Solo?
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Yeah.
SPEAKER 4: "The Folks
Who Live on the Hill."
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Oh, OK.
So here, this is from the CD.
Oops.
OK, [INAUDIBLE] who knows
the composer of that
tune, "The Folks Who
Live on the Hill."
Is it [INAUDIBLE]?
I think so.
I believe that's the composer.
I feel like this
guy [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Ask Google.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Ask Google, yes.
Ask Google, yeah.
Beautiful song.
I've always loved this tune.
I'm just going to play a chorus.
[MUSIC - "THE FOLKS WHO LIVE ON
THE HILL"]
[APPLAUSE]
At the end of the day, people
make the world go round.
So here it is.
We hope you've enjoyed this.
I think perhaps
it's our last tune.
This is also on my latest
recording, "In the Moment."
So if you want to
continue to listen to us,
I'd be happy to sign and
autograph some recordings.
Do we have recordings here?
I don't know, do we?
[LAUGHTER]
I'm just [INAUDIBLE].
[MUSIC - "PEOPLE MAKE THE WORLD
GO ROUND"]
I want to thank Google
for taking the time out
to have us come and
perform for you all.
And this is really wonderful.
I love it.
I'm going to come here
everyday and hang out.
I like this place.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - "PEOPLE MAKE THE WORLD
GO ROUND"]
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW RALLES:
Let's do some Q&A.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Say that again.
ANDREW RALLES: We're going to
do some question and answers.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: OK.
All right.
ANDREW RALLES: So everyone, if
you have your questions ready,
just please line up to
the mic in the aisle here.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: You have
a wonderful audience.
It was very inspirational
to play for today.
Thank you so much.
Wow.
Give yourselves a nice hand.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHNNY O'NEAL: I haven't
gotten warmed up yet.
I'm still trying to
get myself in shape.
OK.
ANDREW RALLES: Thank you.
It was just amazing.
JOHNNY O'NEAL:
Thank you so much.
Pleasure to be here.
ANDREW RALLES: All right,
we have the first question.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
Hi.
Thank you so much for coming.
My question is just about
how you discovered the piano.
Was it the instrument you
always knew you wanted to play?
What was that?
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Well,
that's a good question.
The first time, actually,
I was introduced
to the piano I was at the
age of 13, believe it or not.
I heard my father
play at a house party.
And we didn't have a piano.
He had so many kids he
had to get a day job.
He couldn't make
money playing music.
So anyway, we didn't
have a-- yeah, I said it!
I said it!
So we went to a house party.
And I heard my dad play.
Let me, let me, let me just
demonstrate what I heard
my father play the first time.
And I was so blown
away at 13 years old.
You can imagine
sitting watching this.
[PLAYING BLUES]
This was the first time
I heard my father play.
And I heard him
play this verbatim.
And when he start
doing the roll,
and I said what in
the world is that?
I'm going to show you
the one [INAUDIBLE]..
He went-- and then he went all
the way to the lower register.
[PLAYING BLUES]
This is what you call
tickle [INAUDIBLE]..
I knew then I was sold on
wanting to play the piano.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW RALLES: That
was Erskine Hawkins.
Right?
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Erskine
Hawkins, "After Hours".
Right.
OK.
ANDREW RALLES: Next
question, please.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for sharing
your influences with us
earlier.
This is the centenary
or centennial
of some famous jazz musicians,
one of whom is Thelonious Monk.
And I don't know if you'd
be willing to demonstrate
some of his stylistic playing.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: OK.
AUDIENCE: But also you have
a very personal connection
to him.
I wonder if you
could share that.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Well, actually,
my very first visit to New York
was actually January of '79.
Previous to that, I had
just met Barry Harris.
And Barry said,
when you come to New
York I have a surprise
for you, but he
wouldn't tell me who it was.
So finally, I went to New York.
I drove there actually.
Trying to find him
was just impossible.
It took me three
hours to try to find.
But he was there waiting for me.
So I picked him up.
We drove over to Jersey.
He said Thelonious
Monk, I want you to hear
this young man play the piano.
First visit, first time.
We sat and played all day
long in his living room
overlooking a beautiful palatial
view of the Hudson River.
It was fantastic.
Yeah.
And also, we share
the same birthday.
Who was I just asking-- oh, OK.
Does that answer your question?
You want me to demonstrate
something a little bit of Monk?
OK, let me just a half a chorus.
Now, you know, Monk,
no one else had
been able to really duplicate
that sound because sitting
there watching him
play the piano,
it was so amazing to just
see how he sat and he played.
And he didn't curl his fingers.
You know?
[PLAYING JAZZ]
You know he would
fall down on the beat.
[PLAYING JAZZ]
Let me stop.
That's enough.
[APPLAUSE]
I got out of that.
OK.
Do you remember what
he played for you?
"Ruby, My Dear", "Pannonica".
He played all kind--
oh, man, he played a lot.
And I just sat there
and watched him.
I was like amazed.
See, that's why, you
know, technique--
people always say the
technique is just how fast,
it's how you articulate
what you do is what sound.
Monk was a perfect example.
He didn't he didn't
sound real technical,
but what he did was
highly technical.
It was hard to duplicate
what he played.
And all his
intricate voicings, I
guess what you would
tri-tones and substitution.
No one's been ever to be able
to come up to that level.
You know, I don't think--
in my humble opinion.
Yes.
He had flawless technique.
At one time, I heard an
early recording of him
where someone played
a trick on me.
They said, Johnny,
who is this playing?
I'm listening.
I said, well, no, it
said it's Teddy Wilson.
No, that's Art Tatum.
I'm just going on with the
high level piano players,
as far as facilities.
He said, no, that's
Thelonious Monk.
I was shocked.
He could play like
that at one time.
You know?
So I mean, he was
one of the greatest
composers of the 20th
century, I think so.
You have to know his music.
You know?
You can't sit there and
shout through his music.
You would fall in a
ditch and can't get out.
Really.
It's happened to me many times.
ANDREW RALLES: Did he
have any advice for you?
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Pardon?
ANDREW RALLES: Did Thelonious
have any advice for you?
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Well, he told
me that I have a magic touch.
He said, you know, I'm a
world class piano player.
That's what he said.
Keep continue doing
what I'm doing.
And you know, that was great.
At that time, I
was really young.
I didn't really think of it.
But I'm really blessed now.
Much older now and
for him to say that.
And that's what keeps
my humility in check.
You know?
Yeah.
When I think about all the
great ones that came before me,
people called me great
and call me a king.
No, no, no, no.
I'm a student.
Just like today, as soon as I
got up from his great Steinway,
it said to me, that's all
you got, Johnny, left?
Oh, yes, absolutely.
Oh, yes, perfection
is steady growth.
You always reaching and
striving to be better.
You know?
As for me, every time I sit
down is a learning experience
for me.
Absolutely.
I'm sure all you all being
creative in networking and all,
there's always something.
You can't feel like
you have arrived.
Then you won't grow.
You know?
ANDREW RALLES:
That's great advice.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Thank you.
All right.
ANDREW RALLES: Do we
have any other questions?
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Don't be
scured, as they would say.
ANDREW RALLES:
Please use the mic.
Yeah.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: You all free to
ask my gentlemen questions too
as well, because we do clinics.
And, all over.
And people tend to interview
sometimes my youngsters.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: They have
a lot they want to say.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
Hi.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I was just
curious, how many takes
do you typically do for the
album when you're recording?
And when do you know
when you're finished?
JOHNNY O'NEAL: How many takes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: No more than two.
Usually, the first take
usually is the best one.
The thing about recording,
of course, you're
never going to feel satisfied.
So as long as it feels
good and it sounds good,
then you can live with it.
Then it's OK.
People go in the studio and
take one tune and do 10 takes.
You milking it.
How you going to get
something out of that tune?
So I think one or two
takes are the best.
It's best to record.
Don't listen to it right away.
Play a couple songs, then
go back and listen to it.
Because if you listen to it
once, you're going to go,
oh, I don't like that.
Let's do it over again.
No, no, let it pass.
No, let it pass.
And go back and listen.
And then, like I said, if it
feels right, then it's OK.
That's some of the
greatest records
were all recorded in one room.
They didn't have all these sound
booths and all that back then.
Everybody in one room,
a lot of times one take.
(RASPY VOICE) Let's play
"Along Came Betty" one take.
Out.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: All right.
Are there any musicians out
there as well sitting out
there?
OK.
All right.
Yes?
Oh, I thought I saw someone.
AUDIENCE: So how do you pick
your tunes that you play?
JOHNNY O'NEAL: You say?
AUDIENCE: How do
you pick your tunes?
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Ooh,
how do I pick my tunes?
AUDIENCE: There are so many.
ANDREW RALLES: You
should mention, I mean,
how many tunes are
in your repertoire?
JOHNNY O'NEAL:
Well, that varies.
It depends on the personnel.
I think perhaps
with this trio maybe
we have 200 songs
in a book maybe?
Something like that?
But the last list,
the last count
after all lot the songs I
accumulated at one time,
I had a song list about 1,587
songs, something like that.
But you know, that's
not a lot of tunes
when you think of the
great American songbook.
Ella Fitzgerald had a
repertoire, I was told,
[INAUDIBLE] Ella Fitzgerald had
a repertoire over 5,000 tunes
that I know of.
Plus all the verses.
You know?
That's right.
ANDREW RALLES: That's a lot.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: That's
a lot of tunes, yeah.
And you know, it's
so many tunes that I
forgot that I know because
sometimes I have tunes in mind
that I want to play.
And as soon as I get
on the bandstand,
they just kind of escape me.
And you know, I never
get around to playing--
I say, dog, I should have
played that last night.
That's the way it happens.
It's just endless when
it comes to repertoire.
You know?
ANDREW RALLES: Do you!
Remember the last
tune you added?
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Well, no.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHNNY O'NEAL: No, I don't.
ANDREW RALLES: We
have another question?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So you're from Detroit.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: From Detroit.
AUDIENCE: And I lived in
Ann Arbor for two years.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: OK.
Ann Arbor, we call that
right down the street.
AUDIENCE: It is.
And Detroit is currently
going through sort
of like a revitalization,
rebirth, gentrification,
if you want to call it.
You know, it's
re-growing, et cetera.
And I was wondering if you feel
as though jazz and blues, et
cetera, have a place in sort
of that rebirth of Detroit
and that revitalization?
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Yes.
Well, just being there this past
summer at the jazz festival,
yes.
Detroit is on a
tremendous comeback.
And of course, some of your
most influential musicians
in the world come from Detroit.
I'm not trying to
sound braggadocios,
but that's just the truth.
I mean, when it comes to all
types of music from Motown
to the soul music, Detroit,
Philly, and Pittsburgh,
that's the category of
all of your innovators.
You have innovators,
imitators, and simulators.
And those guys were the
innovators of all this music.
You see?
And Kansas City
too, number four.
Yeah, right.
OK?
Did that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: OK.
All right.
OK.
ANDREW RALLES: Well,
Johnny, thank you so much.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: It was
my pleasure to be.
ANDREW RALLES: This was
just an amazing experience.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: And thank
all you wonderful people.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHNNY O'NEAL: And
my rhythm section.
ANDREW RALLES: Special
thanks to the Talks
at Google team,
Steinway and Sons
also for providing
this beautiful piano.
And hopefully, we'll be back
here with more jazz at Google.
So thanks, everyone.
JOHNNY O'NEAL: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]